I have come together again with one of
my charity who I trust Abdullah who had
100 donation policy we are now raising
funds to build houses for those who have
been homeless due to natural disasters
in Afghanistan Syria and Pakistan please
donate whatever you can may Allah build
you guys at home for helping and
enabling them to have a house
brothers and sisters and dear friends
here's a video of us that's been
circulating my wife showed it to me on
Tick Tock let's watch this for ourselves
and let's see why does somebody even cut
this out and put it up to panel
so guys you saw the videos subhanallah
you can see for example what he's doing
and people are commenting and saying has
he got mental issues has he is he
possessed is there something wrong with
him has he got ADHD has he got this what
lie is this what the ummah has come to
well lie is this what Thomas come to you
man well I am shocked the person who
recorded this did you not fear Allah if
I was to step up a team you won't let
I'll buy you a big gift all the slander
backbiting name calling all that stuff
alhamdulillah that Allah used someone
like you with an evil intention for
something good for about so Allah uses
these evil people Allah use certain
people to get goodness for you now
there's a group of group we have here uh
some Brothers Super selfies all they do
is they back by install this as if
they're like a backbiting bank it's like
Allah created them so the people that
the backbites in the sun against all the
goodies Wildlife as if their creation is
just for that they give all their Good
Deeds to others and if their goodies are
finished they carry the sins of the
others unbelievable alhamdulillah there
was a lot of people defending us and I
just want to say this I need any
clarification nothing I was just
thinking like did you see this what is
this and I'm trying to like say to him
like I know it doesn't get to him I just
said look so ignore these haters
whatever it is yeah subhanallah and
you've got people
uh flipping the dirt off these Earths
anyways yeah so hosting the subhanallah
he prayed he was leaving
praying what he did just adjusting
himself tired yeah okay or his eyes
looking somewhere let me see you pray
tarawi leads Allah Prophet there was a
properly bless him
yeah I don't usually pray about him
giving a false impression
the first was nearly 54 minutes my right
leg went numb numb I was this close to
sitting down this close we're gonna say
oh I look at Ali I don't care about you
bro I would sit down if my lips were not
sit down it's hard and that's one of the
car 54 minutes
he killed us but the point is what
people get tired you get tired he's
holding his hand like this he's tired
yeah if you've done boxing let me see
you hold your hand for three minutes
like this it's hard it's not easy
subhanallah have some good assumptions
of your brother and you're sharing this
fear Allah may Allah deal with you how
are you sharing this video what the hell
have you guys come down to well fear
Allah man the person said the one who
guarantees what's between this what's
between his legs I'll Grant and Jannah
do you know how many people are going to
enter the fight because of this lip lift
this thumb biting slandering just
because he's tired and he looked up once
and he was blinking or his hands were
here the hell is wrong with you people
can someone not get tired
strange and this is in Ramadan in
Ramadan imagine the sins you're
accumulating by putting that post
imagine what Allah if I was going Chase
up with him his feet for forgiveness
imagine Ramadan you broke your fast with
the Flesh of your brother the Flesh of
your brother mocking him you have mental
illness breath your mental you've got
anyone that thinks that that's a mental
illness issue somebody's getting tired
you have psychological issues you have a
mental problem that's what I'm going to
say guys well that is nothing to say I'm
shocked I am shocked today's my family's
getting ready I felt so need to do this
video while I was so shocked what is
wrong with you people alhamdulillah
blessed every single one who defended us
well lie may Allah bless you guys to
defend the honor of a Believer and
that's how his beliefs we should be
bonding looking after one another not
looking for the mistake like certain
individual backstabbers opportunity
backstabbers how can I cash this guy out
let me see ah good I always
punch in the camera